I actually don't care about anything
else speed both in people skills and
hard work will trump anything beam is
fourth billion times more important than
perfection speed when you're not
spending any time worrying you're
spending time on executing that's what a
great culture is its speed you're not
spending the 15 minutes a day dickering
not spending the 4 hours late wondering
if that person is trying to ruin you I
understand it's a race and yet speed is
a variable for success to me in a big
way also and so the patience and speed
are very much rubbing against each other
but like the diamond comes from
[Music]
on your day to day work you have to be
fast with the clients that you know you
you email them back like your day to day
but your vision what you want to achieve
in life you're not going to build it in
one year and so many people have it
reversed in the day to day they're slow
and then the macros they want their
business to be huge to the next step
people talk a big game Gary Vee you're
gonna buy the Jets I'm gonna buy the RAM
yo bro nobody nobody unless they wear a
trust fund baby ever bought the Rams
when they go skiing for a week when
they're 24
I am massively at a global level
patience but on a practical level and an
execution level under fast its ruling
Amelia's religion in church when you
align on religion you can go fast and
such a bigger aspect of business than
people realize and so instead of
jockeying and politicking and pondering
and posturing and debating for three to
four months we're just a few oh now now
when your new road you [ __ ] get [ __ ]
done I just went on a few email for my
guests email ramp to the whole company
it was great
new communication thing about speed in a
15 I've got a lot on an hour and a half
on me now I will impact for our company
for a long time I think it's crazy when
Goliath engines division glides should
never lose to David that means bad
strategy if we're David because it's us
force WPP like get a [ __ ] rock and
put in risk [ __ ] an eye if you don't
people talk about what people think
because everything the reality is I
think Steve Klump so much that I'm blown
away by people that get caught up in
this and really it just leads to you
being disproportionately not successful
because you're too slow you're
overthinking things you would be only
thing that matters and opinions
predicated on people's insecurities and
you go slow [ __ ] down
[Music]
hurry up - life
[Music]